[Music]
feel that breeze
it's a Stellar Wind but not from Good
Old Saul our sun which does that make
your 93 million miles away
this Stellar Wind comes from 32
000 quintillion miles away
the result of a pod to do a dying dance
and the photon momentum pressure that
they provide together as race each other
in a dance for all eternity and it's
also one of the most dramatic
observations of the James Webb Space
Telescope to date come along let's dive
deep into the physics of Dusty Stars
Webb released a vivid image called by
some well really just me the Lord of the
Rings a vivid image of 17 concentric
rings of space dust
pair of stars which orbit around each
other in a parabolic dance of cosmic
proportions creating spectacular Stoller
storms and leaving reverberating
mesmerizing rings of cosmic dust behind
the dynamic duo of stars has been dubbed
with the less than Stellar moniker of
wr-124
binary star systems are common in fact
most stars that you can see in the Milky
Way galaxy with your naked eye are
actually multiple star systems either
double or even Triple Star systems
as many as 85 percent of all stars in
our own Galaxy have a nearby
gravitationally bound dance partner or
two
but this pair this tangoing Duo is an
extra special set
at the closest point to each other the
two stars in wr124 the point in which
astronomers call the periastron the
gravitational interactions between the
two of them peel off giant clouds of
space dust
this space dust cloud gets propelled by
Massive Stellar winds but it only occurs
at regular intervals it's not occurring
continuously these incredible Stellar
winds move at speeds nearing 6 million
miles per hour over a three-dimensional
dance floor that's over 5 000 light
years away from Earth
an astronomical unit is the 93 million
mile distance between the Earth and the
Sun
so this is enormous on a scale of our
entire solar system this great distance
between the two dance Partners doesn't
sound very romantic does it
maybe there's a nearby John Lithgow
chaperoning and supervising them keeping
them separate in the apocal Science
movie Footloose
the dancers here though are giant Stars
not Hollywood heartthrobs and their
dance partners
they're located in the constellation
cygnus 5600 light years away
one of these two dance Partners is a
giant star called a wolf Ray a type star
thousands of times brighter and much
hotter than our sun and in fact 20 times
the mass of our sun this is a rare type
of star that's running so hot that it is
rapidly running out of its hydrogen fuel
and will go supernova long before our
sun meets its end these types of stars
will Fred are namesake of two different
French astronomers one named Charles
Wolff the other one George red who
discovered the first of its kind in
1867. these stars shine bright like a
diamond as Rihanna would say their
signature emission spectrum comes from
Helium nitrogen carbon and oxygen lines
with less hydrogen than a star of
ordinary types
these are rare diamonds too there's only
500 or so of these in our entire galaxy
so each one is precious and that drobe
scientists using the James Webb Space
Telescope to point Webb's powerful
mid-infrared instrument also known as
Miri
towards this famous star system wr124
Miri showed us that this dynamic duo
producing dust is mostly made of
hydrocarbons
the production of hydrocarbons could
play a role in seeding the carbon so
essential for life on Earth throughout
the Universe the companion to the wolf
raid star in the star system wr124 is a
dense muscular and even larger partner
weighing in at about 50 solar masses and
it's not nearly as bright or hot
it's called a blue supergiant
now remember the periastrum that's the
point of closest approach which occurs
periodically as it does for anything
that orbits around another object in
space an ellipse has two Foci one closer
to the mutual center of gravity and one
much farther away
now they get together at regular
intervals precisely every 7.9 years this
produces a massive radial circumstellar
storm
now wr124 has been observed by many many
other teams long before the James Webb
Space telescope's observation
using so-called long Baseline radio
interferometry or vlbi
it was observed previously in the radio
regime of the electromagnetic spectrum
the Keck telescope also looked at longer
wavelengths than we can see with visible
light using infrared cameras and also by
Webb's older brother the Hubble Space
Telescope
but until now these periodic concentric
dust Rings were invisible this star
system held so much promise that Webb
put it as one of its early Science
Program top priorities and aimed the
Miri instrument at it to capture the
cosmic surprises
defying gravitational orbital mechanics
the size and scope of these concentric
smoke rings could only be the result of
the massive solar winds pushing the dust
particles outward to thousands of times
the distance between the Earth and the
Sun
the recurring solar storms of truly
astronomical proportions are blowing
vast amount of cosmic dusts later to be
recycled perhaps
events in the sun such as solar flares
and coronal mass ejections light up the
sky and could even cause a so-called
Carrington event that could disrupt
telecommunications for months or maybe
even years if one of our power stations
were to explode due to the overshock and
what is effectively a giant power surge
this would disrupt navigation and
increase radiation exposure this happens
frequently on Earth and there hasn't
been a Carrington event for over a
century
future space exploration initiatives
like the Breakthrough star shot project
May someday send spacecraft with solar
sails that use these mass ejections and
use the solar wind and the momentum
they're in to accelerate spacecraft out
of our solar system to dance with
distant Stars light years away to learn
what might happen if life in the
universe is discovered on one of the
planets around these other stars click
here and don't forget to subscribe
[Music]